شابه سعوديه تحولت اسمها الى ترند على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي والسبب الشبه
الكبير الذي لحضه الجمهور بينها وبين
جورجينا رودريغيز صديقه نجم كريستيانو
رونالدو القصه بدات بعد نشرها مقطع فيديو
وهي تقلد اطلاله عارضه الازياء
الارجنتينيه التي ارتدتها اثناء استقبال
كريستيانو في ملعب فريق النصر ظهرت شابه
داخل سياره مرتديا نفس اطلاله جورجينا
والميك اب ايضا كما انها قلدت عباره
كريستيانو التي القتها باللغه العربيه
اثناء ترحيبها على جماهير نادي النصر
السعودي الفيديو اثار تفاعل عدد كبير من
رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كما حافظ
على اعجاب الكثيرين لتقارب الشباب بين
الفتاه وبين صديقه رونالدو
مرحبا مرحبا
تجي في بالي كل يوم